whether you are a seasoned professional
or a fresh graduate looking to begin
your career in the industry an I.T
certification can open numerous doors
for you it can give you the technical
knowledge you need to advance your
professional journey and receive
lucrative compensation packages a
certification proves you have the right
skills and experience in a particular
field so if you are watching simply
learn and today we bring you the list of
top 10 certifications for 2023 that will
boost your career
at number 10 we have a web development
web development involves designing and
coding a functioning layout for your
website while maintaining its
compatibility which helps promote your
company effectively and increase sales
revenue simply learns full stack Java
developer course with a job guarantee
covers all web developments ins and outs
from front-end design to server
management the web developer job market
is expected to expand by eight percent
by 2029 substantially greater than the
average for professional roles for web
developers the average salary ranges
from 62 to 158 000 if you're in the US
and 13.7 to 30 lakh rupees for people in
India at number nine we have cyber
security seventy percent of cyber
Security Professionals are required to
be certified by their Employers in the
United States which shows how valuable
certification in cyber security is in
the open market
cyber security Specialists work in
various domains to secure critical
systems and sensitive data while
discovering vulnerabilities and
responding to digital threats in real
time the advanced executive program in
cyber security by simply learn has been
designed in collaboration with iiit
Bangalore and covers the entire subject
from Basics to extremely complex topics
the CCNA ccnp and cissp courses are also
good options offered by CompTIA a cyber
security analyst can earn 84 to 164
thousand dollars working in the United
States or 5 to 40 lakh rupees if they
work in India
at number eight we have agile scrum
businesses of all sizes use the agile
scrum approach because it enables high
level collaboration and efficiency for
project-based work the combination of
scrum and agile framework is of
significant importance in today's market
which is highlighted by a 24 growth
prediction in jobs by 2026.
the certified scrum Master accreditation
provided by scrum Alliance will teach
you how to employ scrum methodologies in
route to the CSM certification a
certified scrum Master can earn from 100
to 170 thousand dollars in the US while
raking in 13 to 20 lakh rupees working
in India
at number seven we have robotic process
automation the automation industry has
been one of the fastest growing
Industries this decade robotic process
automation or RPA is used to build Bots
that can learn imitate and execute
rules-based business processes by
monitoring human digital interactions
the most well-known tools in the RPA
industry are blue prism uipath and
automation anywhere
the RPA certification program from
Simply learn helps you understand RPA
procedures and Industry standards using
the uipath RPA platform while helping
you prepare for the RPA developer
Advanced certification test with the RPA
Market set to grow to 10 billion dollars
by 2023 a certified RPA engineer can
earn up to 88 to 140 thousand dollars
per annum in the United States and 7 to
20 lakh rupees in India at number six we
have PMP certification project
management includes planning and
organizing a company's resources to
complete a certain work event or
responsibility the project manager will
Design and manage the Project Lead the
project team and determine how to
approach the job depending on criteria
such as the type of project the demands
of the company and the skills of project
colleagues simply learns PMP plus
certification includes project
management Concepts scrum Master lean
Six Sigma and much more the project
management professional certification
covers the initiating planning executing
coordinating and closing of projects
approximately 22 million new jobs will
be generated for project management
Focus Personnel through 2027. a
certified project manager can expect to
earn around 74 to 144 thousand dollars
per annum in the United States and 12 to
17 lakh rupees per annum in India at
number five we have big data nearly 2.5
quintillion bytes of data are produced
every day but the expansion of the iot
infrastructure is only ramping up that
pace organizations harness their data
and use big data analytics to discover
fresh opportunities this results in
smarter business decisions increase
profits and happier clients
simply learns Big Data engineer
certification covers all the basics like
Hadoop mongodb Pi spark Etc
alternatively the CCP data engineer
certification will train you to
transform and analyze data in cloudera's
CDH environment with 11.6 million jobs
predicted to open up by 2026 the future
scope is immense when it comes to Big
Data a big data engineer can earn up to
121 to 251 thousand dollars per annum in
the USA while earning 12.3 to 33 lakh
rupees per annum with the right
certification in India at number four we
have digital marketing
digital marketing is vital since it
links a company with its clients while
they are online and operates in so many
sectors the use of SEO and PPC social
media marketing email marketing and
Google helps businesses connect with
their prospective clients you can opt
for simply learns PG program in digital
marketing which will help you master
skills like the fundamentals of digital
marketing SEO web analytics social media
marketing PPC
Etc
since people spend most of their time
online digital marketing is seen as a
Mainstay in the marketing industry
prompting higher paying scales and
increased demands for trained
professionals
a digital marketing manager can earn
between 60 to 160 thousand dollars per
annum working in the United States while
the same will net you 7 to 16 lakh
rupees per annum in India
at number three we have data science
data science is crucial in generating
new ideas and making sense of data since
it combines the subject matter expertise
of programming mathematics and
statistics data science combines
scientific techniques and algorithms to
extract only relevant and helpful
insights from a vast amount of data
simply learns data science Master
certification can help you get started
with python SQL data visualization and
machine learning
harvardx's data science professional
certification covers similar topics
using the r programming language with
data science automation trending
nowadays data science employment rates
are predicted to grow drastically in
2023 data scientists with the right
certification can earn up to 115 to 246
thousand dollars per annum in the United
States while those in India can earn up
to 8.2 to 20 lakh rupees per annum
at number two we have cloud computing
Big Data artificial intelligence and
machine learning are some of the newly
developing Technologies driving the
worldwide market for cloud computing
cloud computing which enables
organizations to store manage and
analyze crucial data uses remote
machines that are hosted online the AWS
certified Solutions architect associate
certification will enhance your ability
to architect deploy and secure
applications on AWS Cloud servers
similarly the Microsoft certified Azure
administrator helps professionals Master
deployment on Azure servers the global
cloud computing Market is set to grow by
20 between 2022 and 2029 a cloud
computing engineer earns 145 to 227
thousand dollars per annum in the US
while those working in India can earn 16
to 24 lakh rupees per annum
at number one we have ai and machine
learning your industry may require AI
experts very soon considering how
machine learning employment trends keep
growing in fields like deep learning and
natural language processing
AI is the design of computer systems
that can carry out tasks traditionally
requiring human intelligence
computers May learn and develop as they
have been exposed to database scenarios
thanks to a particular type of AI called
machine learning
simply learns postgraduate Ai and
machine learning program have been
designed in partnership with Purdue
University and IBM covering Concepts
like NLP statistics python machine
learning Etc alternatively Stanford's
machine learning certification is
available which covers an introduction
to machine learning statistical pattern
recognition data mining Etc
according to Gartner the AI software
Market is slated to become a 62 billion
dollar industry by 2023. the average
salary of an AI engineer is 140 to 386
thousand dollars per annum in the U.S
and between 6 and 20 lakh rupees in
India
so there you have it the top 10
certifications for 2023. if you need
help with any of the domains mentioned
in this video we have links for our
created courses by simply learn in the
description box thank you for watching
and stay safe
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here